yeah hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back - will you
press the button again I don't need to
explain this much like would you rather
but just in case you haven't seen it
before you press the button you get the
power but there's always a catch and you
don't have to press the button so you
gain the ability to teleport as many
times as you wish at any time but where
you teleport is random would you press
the button I absolutely would not
because what if you teleport randomly
into the middle of the ocean what if you
teleport anywhere in the universe what
have you teleports literally anywhere in
space die in seconds and then everything
is bad teleport into the center of the
earth that is not good I will not press
that button that's bad it's good lemma
though I guess if people really want
that will you press this button you can
understand animals but all animals you
listen to will come to resent it and
complain about you to each other behind
your back oh those sassy animals well I
mean that'd be cool I don't have to live
with animals I can just understand them
and that means they have an intelligence
enough to talk about me behind my back
what I mean is pretty cool though I mean
I'd just be that annoying human that
comes on hey just trying to be animals
brogues go please dear God just leave us
alone I press the button that sounds
awesome
I don't care oh no I couldn't be around
chica she would come to resent with this
horrible power anyway Steve Jobs will be
brought back from the dead but every
single iOS project product will vanish
well you know I've like no offense to
Steve Jobs I mean I know his family
probably wants him back but personally
it doesn't really matter one way or
another to me because there's a lot of
hero-worship about Steve Jobs and sure
he created Apple and all that stuff but
as far as like you know they're here now
I mean he lived a full life kind of he
was was he in his 60s I don't think I
press that button that's not and there's
no need let history be history it's not
that I want like the products that he
made to stay around it's just like what
would it matter
like he was old he was gonna have
another few no no no what would you do I
don't know
let's see you live in Hawaii but you
have a unibrow living in Hawaii is a
choice I mean it's a little more it's a
lot more expensive over there but I was
born in Hawaii but I'd have a unibrow I
could just move there without my unibrow
I don't have to bring my unibrow with me
not that I have a unibrow let's not get
any ideas here perfectly split nonsense
there's anything wrong if you have a
unibrow I don't really care one weird
again this is indifferent to me I don't
really mind I'm gonna not press a button
but you can do whatever you want over
there so they're good fine I guess
someone said some of the comments here
said you could just shave but oh that's
good whatever whatever okay you create
an amazing pastry dish and become
internationally famous and wealthy and
handsome let's add that on but the
person who you love dearest has an
allergic reaction to it and dies oh oh
that's horrible oh that's horrible
why would you do there's plenty of
pastry dishes that's not necessary
who would want to be famous for a pastry
dish what kind of legacy would that
leave if the one you love the most is
dead I will not 20 only 25% of people
would have press that one good jeez
that's so dark all right you will be
very rich no definition but you have an
incurable disease that will kill you
unexpectedly well we all die eventually
but when is unexpectedly unexpected live
doesn't say Oh a lot I mean it's one or
another like is being wealthy worth
knowing the death actually I think the
sense of dread from having death looming
over your shoulder at all times at
random would be way way WAY worse than
just living a perfectly fine ordinary
life without being really which where
you could potentially in the future
become rich not I've not pressed a lot
of buttons in this batch yeah now many
people were to press that button okay
you can smell and taste colors but you
are blind
why would I want to smell taste colors
what would that even do what just take
some LSD I guess isn't that the thing
that it does I don't know I've never
taken LSD I'm no expert
LSD experts in the comments those who
have taken it I'm really being serious
now if you have taken LC not that I
condone it not that I ever would not
that I'm telling anybody to do this but
people will do their own things in their
own choices and that's perfectly fine
with me
what was the experience like was it
could you see could you smell and taste
colors like would that even be worth
being blind I don't want to do that
I can see colors just fine and
appreciate that but you know just as an
aside many of my good fans that have
tried it okay you can get a [ __ ] from
any woman in the world but you may never
have another [ __ ] for the rest of
your life no no just no I'm not even
gonna discuss this one no there's a bad
one that's stupid okay every time you
sneeze you earn a thousand dollars and
put yet every time you sneeze someone
you know closer distance gets cancer no
no these are all horrible these are all
so bad no that's so bad oh I've got this
one not the point
okay you can have any pickup truck ever
created exactly how you want it but if
anyone asks you to help them move it you
have a move with it so I can't read
right you have to I don't I don't want a
pickup truck I don't want to visit a
very targeted questionnaire this is very
obviously targeted question here no I
don't want a pickup truck
I'm fine the truckasaurus wrecks Oh Oh
what if I wanted my pickup truck to be
his spaceship they can travel faster
than light oh oh and then everyone would
ask me to move with it oh I guess okay
then the government asked me to move the
entire human population with it anyway I
guess I didn't think that one through
all right everything you eat will be
teleported inside a random person but
you poop for you but that's
Double Down sides you poop for both of
you and every you don't get to keep
everything you eat well that's horrible
what you die you would die you would
literally die you wouldn't get any food
like it's who you would die
what kind of anorexic person made this
question you would die no that's so
stupid
oh man and plus it's only twice as much
poop I guess but no oh c'mon a real but
anytime you eat meat you're eating
Pokemon and that makes sense because in
the world of Pokemon whenever they're
eating meat obviously what would they be
eating there's no animals there there's
there's only Pokemon there's literally
only Pokemon there they're all Pokemon
when they're eating something they're
eating Pokemon I mean there's obviously
vegetarian stuff but okay I'm down I'm
down down down and the people that don't
want to eat pokemons anyway I can
already hear the comments rage debating
down there before okay calm down it's
okay comments it's fine your life will
be filled with action and adventure but
you're the main hero sidekick doesn't
sound so bad the main hero sidekick
unless it's like the cliche version like
Robin and the old Batman and Robin with
what's-his-face that guy that voices
stuff on family guy now but like even if
you're the sidekick you get to see all
these cool things like the sidekick is
still appreciated even though for
Batman's sidekick they have a lot of
terrible things happening dude but it's
not that bad I would go for that that
sounds pretty cool let's see ya 69% of
people who do that oh yeah they would
see you get any video game you want for
free but the publishers of the game make
no money so this is literally like
pirating games right now this is
literally that's literally just pirating
games and I don't pirate games I used to
pile on time ago
my pirated games but even like even even
like initially I thought it was totally
fine and then I realized it's just
really stupid and kind of stealing but I
don't like again I'm not I'm not stop
getting in a debate about things life is
chill be chill talk with the LSD fans
totally chill like yeah it's like III
just would rather support the developers
whenever I want to buy a game that I
want to buy so I would not I would not
what 63% of people would have print
that's douchey you become the perfect
man had every woman I read the other
part every woman you beat loves you and
wants you but you have a small peepee
but you have a small peepee what did a
twelve-year-old write this would you be
so popular but you peepee so small oh
that's hilarious oh man no I would no
thank you
Wow 46% of people would have press this
button thank you oh there's a lot of
comments that are saying like well it
wouldn't change anything I bet but not
me though shut up I'm liking that just
for the fact it made me laugh okay
you'll be immune to any and every
disease but you will not be able to bend
to any of the joints in your body ever
again there are a lot of joints in the
body there are a lot of joints a lot of
joints but okay hear me out about this
that would be a torturous horrible
existence it almost wouldn't be worth
living of course you wouldn't press the
button and I'm actually gonna leave this
up to you guys now I'm not gonna leave
this up to you guys I'll get another one
but my argument for this is if you've
had to live that life your body has
immunity to every disease if scientists
were able to study your immunity they
would be able to see how your body works
to be immune to every disease and then
put that immunity out into the public
and then that would be able to cure
every disease they're talking to every
disease if they could study you and
maybe you know maybe that's the end of
your life maybe you don't want to live
any longer maybe that maybe you can't
live any longer like immune to every
disease but horribly horribly horribly
crippled for the rest of your life
but in that instance you would be able
to
sure everyone else is everything now
there's no guarantee of that happening
but the chance the chance the chance the
chance the opportunity for that to
happen I would press upon I would press
that by oh my god only 18 percent of
people would press that button but still
that the possibility the possibility
okay you get to work your dream job but
you get paid minimum wage and have to
live off welfare to survive now that's a
tough one so I'll leave this one up to
you because there's two sides to this
you could be totally happy in what you
do for your dream job but you'd never
get paid well for it that's what a lot
of people do that's the debate a lot of
people do in their real life they you
know they don't know if they want to go
for the job that they really love or
they want to go for the job that they
really want or need you know job that
pays a lot of money or job that really
satisfies so I'll leave that to you guys
let me know what you would do in the
description below would you press this
button and thank you everybody so much
for watching if you want to see more of
this let me know down in the comments
below I would love to read you guys
responses to this video thank you again
everybody and as always I will see you
in the next video